my earliest memories are of him being
violent towards me and towards other
other people in the couch I kept in the
house of the time I wasn't allowed to go
out
glad to die and be free for Katie Davies
a simple walk in the park is something
she once dreamed of born into a cruel
sect she was kept in captivity for three
decades
her father is Aravind and Bala Krishnan
who founded the workers Institute's
once based on Maoist ideology but soon
characterized by violence and fear it
was not so much Marxist and Maoist as a
cult of Bala as a person so he took what
he thought suited him from that ideology
as well as from other things to promote
himself because he's basically in
narcissistic psychopath really and just
wants everybody to worship Him and do as
he says without question and he was
obsessed about controlling other people
he loved violence and those totalitarian
dictatorships and then he'd really loved
that because I think he wanted to be
like that he wanted to be like Stalin or
Mao or Pol Pot where everybody just
listens to him and if they don't and
they he can kill them without with
impunity I mean when when I was a child
I was taught that he knows everything
he's God he's the ruler of the universe
and everything he says is correct and
did you ever question it as a child or
as a teenager not as a child because I
didn't know anything else though I
didn't like it sometimes but when there
was violence it was often said that that
was doing help me to improve
I just have to sing the songs in praise
of him and I used to have to write spend
about two hours in the morning writing
we used to stand around and listen to
him as he gave lectures sometimes he
would target someone or another either
me or somebody else in the house and the
whole lecture would be about shouting at
that person and denied rating that
person she lived not just in fear of
balakrishnan but also his fictitious
omnipotent mind control machine Jackie
if I did something wrong well others and
me he we would be killed by Jackie but
that if he intervenes by slapping us and
beating us and cussing us and things
then Jackie would think that that enough
has been done and not kill us so we
should be thankful that he's hurting us
and being violent whatever he was doing
because we were being saved from
Jackie's wrath shut away in a bedroom
for 30 years her isolation was extreme
kept even from knowing that one of the
people she lived with was her mother she
later learned it was Shawn Davies who
died in 1997 after falling from an open
window when while she was alive there
was no affection between us so it was
not like I missed her when she passed
away in fact in a way when she after she
fell from the window things got better I
mean I was really strange and it's not
nice to say that but because she was one
of the worst as is in many cults family
relationships and that sort of thing is
not encouraged because it's seen as
detrimental to following the cult leader
so because she was my mum she was like
trying to go out of her way to prove to
my dad that she puts him before me Bella
robbed us of that connection from what
I've heard from her family she was very
nice person but the cult turned her into
a
shadow of her former self and may turn
to something that she was not so I
didn't ever really know her as she truly
was the women in the collective Ambala
as he was known were her only points of
human contact Katie never went to school
had friendships or another child to play
with in so on and some of the houses we
live there was neighbors have children
and if the children came out to play and
sometimes they should look through the
fence and look at me and those with me
used to say that they are fascist agents
trying to lure me away from the
collective so that they can kill me I
used to feel suicidal as well many times
remember feeling suicidal at the age of
six
Katie tried to escape but in one of many
missed opportunities the authorities had
to help her over the decades the police
sent her back to her captor I told him
that I had run away from home and long
and short of it is they persuaded me to
call him and to go back home why did
they send me back it was a bank holiday
eight years later she finally did escape
with the help of a charity her life was
in immediate danger with untreated type
1 diabetes I would have died no to pay
two partridge
well I would have died anyway even if I
hadn't died of diabetes I would have
committed suicide because I just
couldn't bear living like her this isn't
a non-person
and worse than an animal I couldn't bear
living like that rather die and be free
on that day Friday October 25th when
mother and child I went out shopping as
usual we walked hot how did that feel
best feeling in the world free for the
first time ever and I never thought that
they would ever come and it did
did you realize at the time that this
was it that you were leaving that you
would not go back to that life certainly
yes so you weren't gonna let anybody
send you back at this time I was scared
a bit when I came out thinking that what
if they come back and find me and then
they make up a story and that's somehow
that he was not the way I said it was
and then those who ever was with me
would send me back but no once once it
was I thought I was free
now katie has embarked on the long task
of learning ordinary life for the first
time and I first came out I had no sense
of direction at all I wasn't able to
find my way around even hardly just down
the road and it couldn't cross the road
or take public transport anything like
that just be able to walk out the door
on my own on the street and make friends
with people talk to people without
permission and see what I want without
fear of being killed or cursed or
whatever and wear what I want to wear
peace my ears dye my hair the small
little things but it's just so so
amazing